wer weiß schon
heute morgen sind wir mal wieder als
neubeginn 16 wir sind 16 willkommen zu
unserem band tagebuch wir sind eine band
aus münchen im fahnen durch deutschland
musizieren erleben viele geschichten
zeigen euch wie das leben in deutschland
ist nehmen euch mit auf die reise
erfahren
berlin inn von der ehemaligen hofstelle
in deutschland ja wir sind in köln
wir sind hier beim fc bayern münchen auf
dem münchner oktoberfest dance kennen
wir stellen euch jetzt die band vor
ja ich bin der kurz rapper und boxer
wenn ich nicht gerade übermäßig
unterwegs bin bin ich zeichne und
inspirator und gestaltet
was immer wir auch auf betragen wird ich
bin trotz ich bin zuständig für den
neben der musik bin ich noch sprecher
schauspieler und musikproduzent hallo
liebe leute ich bin der bastille von 16
ich spiele klavier
wenn ich nicht beim sex bin dann arbeite
ich nebenher als der wie ein tempel
bauer
hallo leute ich bin lorenz ich bin
geiger der band musiker geiger von beruf
ihr seht spiele ich nicht eine geige wie
man die üblicherweise sieht sondern ein
schwarzes plastikmodell hey ich bin der
thomas ich bin der park assist von 16
ich bin mit meiner freizeit ein
begeisterter tänzer das ist der anblick
der an dies zuständig für den bass
groove
in den nächsten monaten werden wir euch
mehr erzählen was im leben einer jungen
bands abgeben ich bin als ich bin
percussion ist bei 16 und ich bin auch
beim papa
und noch dazu wenn ich einer der beiden
kameraleute vom band tagebuch 1 hoch 6
wir machen das ganz besonderes nämlich
musik insbesondere in 16 ist dass sich
klassische musiker mit hip hoppern
zusammengetan haben dass wir so viele
unterschiedliche charaktere sind
zwischen guter laune seriosität und es
trotzdem
doch immer wieder schaffen gute stimmung
auf der bühne drehen aufgeht